[Musik]
herzlich willkommen meine Damen und
Herren zu fällt dir nach acht fünf Köpfe
5 Meinungen es ist der 19 Tag von Putins
Krieg der ukrainische Präsident selenski
will ein vier augengespräch mit Vladimir
Putin der deutsche Bundeskanzler Olaf
Scholz und der türkische Präsident
Erdogan fordern Waffenruhe und Christian
Lindner unser Finanzminister will die
Autofahrer mit einem Tankrabatt
entlasten was können wir gegen die
explodierenden Energiepreise tun und wie
ist die Lage in Kiew wo es heute ein
Angriff auf ein Hochhaus gab darüber
möchte ich heute sprechen mit im
früheren Verkehrsminister andreas
Scheuer im FDP-Politiker Maximilian
Mordhorst dem stellvertretenden
Chefredakteur pauronsheimer der uns wie
jeden Abend live aus Kiew zugeschaltet
ist und dem Forschungsdirektor der
Deutschen Gesellschaft für auswärtige
Politik Dr Christian Mölling lass uns
keine Zeit verlieren und direkt zu Power
und sei mal nach Kiew schalten Paul wie
ist die Lage vor Ort
ja schönen guten Abend aus Kiew in die
Runde mittlerweile gehen wir in die
dritte Woche oder in die vierte Woche
bereits des gesamten Krieges gegen die
Ukraine ich weiß nicht ob es ein guter
Abend ist denn gerade eben sind wieder
sie reden losgegangen und wir haben im
Nordosten direkt hinter uns bei einer
Live-Schalte die Explosion sehen können
das ist wie ein Feuerball der dann da in
der Nacht zu sehen ist und heute den
ganzen Tag über gab es bereits Horror
Nachrichten auch hier aus Kiew am Morgen
wurde ein Wohnhaus angegriffen es gab
mehrere Tote mindestens zwei mehrere
Verletzte danach bin ich mit den beiden
Klitschko Brüdern zu einem weiteren
Tatort so nenne ich es ein Tatort der
von Putins Raketen angegriffen wurde ein
Bus völlig zerstört ein Haus wir haben
dort Leichen gesehen und Kiews
Bürgermeister Vitali Klitschko an der
Seite sein Bruder Wladimir Klitschko war
nur noch fassungslos als ich mit ihnen
dort durch die komplett fast zerstörte
Straße gelaufen bin
und Vitali Klitschko dennoch gesagt wir
werden nicht aufgeben wir werden nicht
aufhören uns hier zu verteidigen aber
das was heute in Kiew passiert ist das
was wir gesehen haben in Kiew lässt
Schlimmes vermuten für die nächsten Tage
und Wochen und möglicherweise ist es so
dass die scheinbaren
Friedensverhandlungen von Putin nur
angeboten wurden um hier weiteres Unheil
anzurichten weitere Menschen die sterben
müssen und die Ukraine die Bitten
verzweifelt und sagen sperrt endlich den
Luftraum und gibt uns mehr Waffen
Herr Dr mörling wenn Sie das hören wie
könnte man denn diesen Krieg beenden was
muss passieren wie könnte man vielleicht
ja doch dann noch aufeinander zugehen
oder wie soll man sich eigentlich
gegenüber dem Aggressor Vladimir Putin
Verhalten ja ich glaube wir sehen ja
gerade das ist auf der einen Seite schon
Gesprächsangebote aus der Ukraine heraus
gibt es gibt den glaube schon den Willen
zu verhandeln denn selensky sieht dass
er das nicht unendlich durchhalten kann
aber es ist die russische Seite die sich
bewegen muss Europa die NATO all die
können hier nicht mithelfen es sind die
beiden Parteien die im Grunde genommen
zum Schluss kommen müssen wir haben aber
jetzt zur Zeit eine Situation immer noch
wo man sagen muss das muss dann im
Grunde um die Pistole an den Kopf weil
der Ukraine hält und das sind keine
fairen Verhandlungen zum jetzigen
Zeitpunkt es geht immer noch ein
Kapitulation und deswegen ist der
Widerstand der Zeit stattfindet in Kiew
und in der gesamten Ukraine so wichtig
in der kauft uns Zeit damit dass die
dass die Sanktionen wirken können und
damit die Situation für Putin schwerer
wird
Paul das Thema Sanktionen wurde gerade
angesprochen du bist vor Ort wie nehmen
die Menschen es dort auch was wollen sie
von Europa und ich weiß gar nicht immer
wenn du es erklärst wie ich die Bilder
kommentieren soll weil sie so furchtbar
sind aber was wird jetzt erwartet wie
kann wie kann es also was können wir tun
damit es jetzt nicht noch in Woche 4 5 6
7 8 9 und die nächsten Monate läuft
dieser schreckliche Krieg
ja ich glaube dass der ukrainische
Präsident unbedingt verhandeln will er
sagt ja auch immer wieder dass er mit
Wladimir Putin an einem Tisch will und
angeblich wollen will die russische
Regierung das ja auch so tun Sie
zumindest allerdings ist es so dass sie
ihre Bedingungen formulieren und da sind
Bedingungen dabei die für den
ukrainischen Präsidenten nur schwer zu
akzeptieren sind und selbst wenn er sie
akzeptieren würde man davon ausgehen
muss dass die Bevölkerung sie nicht
akzeptieren würde nämlich vor allem die
Frage einer Demilitarisierung also im
Land das gerade dabei ist sich zu
verteidigen gegen Russland dieses Land
dazu zu bringen zu sagen wir geben unser
Militär völlig auf ist eigentlich so gut
wie unmöglich und sehr schwer wird es
auch bei der Frage was mit den Regionen
passiert die bereits von Moskau von
Russland von russischen Armee erobert
wurden zum Beispiel einzelne mittelgroße
Städte wo man ja sehen kann dass die
Bevölkerung eben nicht darauf gewartet
hat dass die russische Armee dort ist
und dass die russische Flagge gehisst
wird sondern ganz im Gegenteil wird dort
sehen dass Ukrainer mutige Ukrainerinnen
und Ukrainer weiter auf die Straße gehen
und gegen diese russische Armee gegen
diese Besetzung demonstrieren also es
ist auch für den ukrainischen
Präsidenten ein schweres moralisches
Dilemma auf der einen Seite will er
diesen Krieg beenden auf der anderen
Seite weiß er dass er ihn nicht mit
unter allen Bedingungen beenden beenden
kann denn wenn er das macht was putin
will dann ist die Ukraine Geschichte
Herr scheuer sie sind ja gerade naja die
Union regiert jetzt gerade nicht mehr
sind in der Opposition macht den gerade
die Regierung einen guten Job mit Blick
auf putinskrieg
muss man sagen dass die Opposition aus
CDU und CSU
vernünftig ist
zusammensteht mit den Herausforderungen
in der Welt ich weiß dass es viele
Gespräche gibt auch mit den
Regierungsvertretern und unseren
Fraktionsvorsitzenden Parteivorsitzenden
ich finde das gut weil ich glaube wir
müssen als westliche Welt zusammenstehen
das was wir einfordern hat Wirkung
nämlich das Einstehen in Europa zusammen
auch im Bündnis mit der NATO des denke
ich hat große Wirkung gezeigt davon ist
Putin sicherlich überrascht von der
Geschlossenheit an dieser Stelle dennoch
gibt es natürlich einige Themen die man
anders machen würden und wir würden
natürlich auch gerade den Bundeskanzler
in einer doch
stärkeren Rolle gerne sehen da haben wir
dazu gelernt nach angela Merkel ist
die Spitze der Bundesregierung doch ein
bisschen ja ruhiger zurückhaltender als
es noch die Zeit vorher war also wenn in
Israel dann verhandelt werden soll auf
neutralen Boden zum einen beantragt die
Ukraine die EU-Mitgliedschaft und dann
schaue ich mir macron Scholz an dann
würde ich mir da mehr erwarten aber das
ist eine Rampe merkung wir müssen jetzt
zusammenstehen als deutsche für den
Frieden und wenn man diese Bilder sieht
und ja auch was die Reporte die
Journalisten dort leisten ich kann nur
mein hohen Respekt zahlen aber ich habe
gerade aktuell den Bericht meines
landesgruppenvorsitzenden Alexander
Dobrindt gehörte mit einer kleinen
Delegation an der polnischen Grenze war
gerade die Polen leisten da immenses in
der Aufnahme von Flüchtlingen und wir
müssen uns vorbereiten und da fordere
ich von der Bundesregierung mehr Aktion
auf eine riesigste Flüchtlingswelle
vielleicht auch von anderen ausgenutzt
wird diese Flüchtlingswelle auch
Schleuserbanden haben das schon gemerkt
also das sind alles Erscheinungen
Entwicklungen denen wir uns stellen
müssen und wo wir unsere humanitäre
Kraft einbringen müssen trotzdem die
Herausforderungen werden von Tag zu Tag
größer nicht nur im Kriegsgebiet sondern
die Auswirkungen auf Europa ohnehin und
da sind wir noch nicht einmal bei den
Energiepreisen und vieles mehr
sie sind bei der FDP und dementsprechend
können sie eigentlich direkt darauf
einsteigen was Herr scheuer gesagt hat
ja selbstverständlich also im Grundsatz
glaube ich sind wir uns da auch sehr
sehr einig es ist wichtig insbesondere
aufgrund unserer außenpolitischen
Verlässlichkeit die Putin glaube ich
auch wirklich überrascht hat das stimme
nicht zu dass wir jetzt auch zumindest
was die staatstragenden Parteien angeht
zusammenstehen deswegen unterstütze ich
das durchaus und es stimmt wir sind auf
große Wellen vorbereitet was die
Flüchtlinge angeht Polen leistet
immenses wir haben erste Zahlen das ist
so ungefähr ein Drittel dessen was 2014
bis 17 kam nach Deutschland kam jetzt
schon bei uns angekommen ist immer noch
kein Vergleich zu Polen aber völlig
richtig wir müssen uns darauf
vorbereiten darauf vorbereiten bin aber
Überzeugung sowohl was man
beispielsweise hier am Berliner
Hauptbahnhof sieht wo freiwillige Helfer
Außerordentliches leisten aber auch
ansonsten ist die Politik darauf gut
vorbereitet und die Aufnahmebereitschaft
der Menschen ist auch etwas was mich
jeden Tag mit Respekt erfüllt und
beeindruckt im Modus darf ich das nur
sagen ich würde mir wünschen so eine
organisatorische Professionalität von
dem aktuellen Bericht aus dieser
Delegation die von uns dort an der
Grenze war mit Software Unterstützung
mit
aller Registrierung mit
organisatorischen Abläufen dass das auch
zum Beispiel am Berliner Hauptbahnhof an
dieser Stelle neben der humanitären
Verantwortung neben dem was die Menschen
alles leisten die Hilfsorganisationen
sehe ich doch bei den großen Mengen
schon noch organisatorischen
Nachholbedarf in Deutschland und das
müssen wir halt gemeinsam auch in
Verantwortung zusammen mit den
Bundesländern und den Kommunen
hinbekommen
aber trotzdem wir müssen uns auch auf
das vorbereiten dass die ja
Kriegshandlungen dazu führen dass nicht
nur Frauen und Kinder flüchten und
kommen sondern dass auch noch mal
größere Flüchtlingsströme zu uns kommen
die wir dann versorgen müssen aufnehmen
müssen auch vielleicht sogar medizinisch
versorgen müssen ich nehme das mal sehr
ernsthaft mit ich will das gar nicht
parteipolitisch jetzt irgendwie
aufdröseln ich habe erst heute wieder
mit einem Vertreter der freiwilligen
Helfer gesprochen der auch uns da sehr
genaue Ideen und Rückmeldungen gegeben
hat also wir bleiben dann Austausch und
ich glaube das ist auch vernünftig so
Paul ich habe ja ich habe dich eh schon
gehört dann fang du direkt an
ich störe ja diesen diesen Frieden
sozusagen jetzt im doppelten Sinne dann
nur sehr ungerne wie sie sich alle auf
die Schulter klopfen wie großartig
Deutschland das macht und wie toll wir
helfen ja die Menschen helfen die Bürger
helfen das stimmt auf der anderen Seite
sollte man sich sollte man nicht
aufhören sich unangenehme Fragen zu
stellen denn
sie tun jetzt so als wäre das gegeben ja
der Krieg wird jetzt heute schlimmer und
dann sterben mehr Menschen und mehr
Menschen flüchten und wir tun so als
hätten wir schon alles getan um den
Menschen hier zu helfen das haben wir
nämlich nicht gerade eben vor acht
Minuten hat das Esstische Parlament
übrigens ein NATO-Mitglied dafür
gestimmt eine Flugverbotszone
einzurichten das bedeutet erstmal gar
nichts aber es zeigt dass es durchaus
starken gibt in der NATO und insgesamt
auch in Europa ähm die dazu bereit sind
der Ukraine zu helfen im weiteren Sinne
wie in Deutschland wir waren nicht mal
bereit ein Öl und Gas im WAGO
mitzutragen was die USA zum Beispiel
längst beschlossen haben ich muss sagen
wenn ich hier in der Ukraine unterwegs
bin und nicht Leute treffe die ich nicht
ohnehin schon kenne also ich weiß nicht
ob ich immer noch im ersten Satz sage
ein Paul from Germany ja also manchmal
habe ich das Gefühl langsam hier in der
Ukraine da versteht keiner mehr was
unser Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz dann
macht was die Bundesregierung da macht
warum sie wieder so halbherzig agiert
warum sie zwar Sanktionen umsetzt aber
nicht zu entscheiden dass sie wirklich
überraschen können und da würde ich auch
ein scheuer widersprechen das Putin in
irgendeiner Form mit diesen Sanktionen
nicht gerechnet hätte wir müssen bei dem
Punkt bleiben dass wir weiterhin
Milliarden einem Diktator und einem
Kriegsverbrecher überweisen da können
sich jetzt noch so häufig auf die
Schulter klopfen wie toll wir alles
machen
also vielleicht kann ich dann noch mal
zwei Punkte dazu bringen der
Flugverbotszone erstens heißt Krieg
Eintritt der NATO das heißt wir schießen
russische Flugzeuge ab egal ob es jetzt
zu meinem Besten oder bei der gesamten
Ukraine machen das ist ein Risiko
insbesondere unter der Bedingung dass
die russischen Truppen jetzt schon auf
Konvention Seite so schlecht aufgestellt
sind dass uns an die nukleare Schwelle
deutlich näher dran bringt das ist für
uns das Dilemma diese Verantwortung
müssen wir irgendwann übernehmen und
dazu sagen wir zurzeit nein und das
würde ich unterstützen ich gebe einen
runter aber insofern Recht die
Diskussion über die Tagespolitik ist
schön und gut dieser Konflikt wird in
zwei Wochen ganz anders aussehen wir
werden in zwei Wochen massiven Beschuss
der Ballungszentren haben wahrscheinlich
auch von Kiew noch mehr schreckliche
Bilder noch mehr Flüchtlinge nicht durch
den Beschuss sondern die sind jetzt auf
dem Weg zu uns und wir müssen uns darauf
einstellen dass es einfach selbst wenn
irgendwann der schießkrieg aufhört
keinen Frieden gibt das heißt die
Sanktionen wenn wir über Jahre hinweg
aufrechterhalten müssen diese Welt wird
danach eine andere sein die
sicherheitsoffen die wir vorher mal
geglaubt haben zu haben wird es nicht
mehr geben sie werden entweder eine
Friedensordnung haben die ohne Russland
funktioniert oder im Notfall sogar gegen
Russland funktionieren muss
und ich bin dafür dass wir uns selber
nicht schwächen nur ein starkes
Deutschland ein starkes Europa aber es
die
Energielieferungen betrifft kann dann in
der Folge helfen wenn wir selber die
Auswirkungen zu spüren bekommen und wir
spüren sie ja jetzt schon dann glaube
ich ist es viel zu kurz gesprungen ich
weiß dass er ronsheimer natürlich jetzt
in einem Einsatz ist der alles
emotionale auch abverlangt und wir
können es von diesem schönen Studio aus
gar nicht beurteilen was dafür
Leistungen gemacht werden nur ich sage
nochmal auch USA handelt jetzt nicht als
allumfassend nur an andere denken
sondern da gibt es auch eine Strategie
America first als Stichwort um zu sagen
ich versorge mich jetzt mit meiner
eigenen Energie oder gehe andere
Partnerschaften mit Venezuela und vieles
mehr
danke dass Sie das so sagen ja ich
glaube ich stimme da voll und ganz Herr
Mölling denn wir befinden uns gerade in
einer ganz harten Auseinandersetzung
über politische Systeme mittel und
langfristig Stichwort China Stichwort
die Ausrichtung also wenn jetzt Russland
zum Discountpreis billigst Energien nach
China liefern kann dann geht der der
Spread immer weiter auseinander China
kann noch günstiger produzieren noch
intensiver den Weltmarkt Eintritt machen
und in Europa wird halt Deutschland am
stärksten geschwächt und das will ich
nicht weil wir wenn wir stark bleiben
dann können wir auch unseren Beitrag
leisten unsere Stärke geht über die
Wirtschaft und diesen Rückstoß der
Sanktionen den erleben wir heute schon
und der darf nicht stärker werden wir
jetzt auch gleich
mit Ihnen Herr mortos ich möchte aber
noch einmal Paul fragen ob er noch etwas
entgegnen will denn das ist ja seine
These heute Abend bevor wir dann zur
nächsten these kommen zu den
Energiepreisen
Paul hast du mich gehört
ich habe dich gehört ich habe gerade
eine Nachricht entgegengenommen über
einen verletzten Fox News Journalisten
das musste ich einmal hier wahrnehmen
also gestern ist er bereits ein
us-kollege bei der Berichterstattung
muss Leben gekommen und ein weiterer Fox
News Kollege Benjamin Hall ist verletzt
worden
außerhalb von Kiew es gibt bislang noch
nicht genügend Informationen offenbar
dass es gerade eine Mitteilung die von
Fox News veröffentlicht wurde das musste
ich nur einmal zur Kenntnis nehmen
weiß man nie was man erwidern soll
sondern das hoffentlich alle
Journalisten auch dort gut auf sich
aufpassen aber da möchte ich dir dann
einfach noch eine Frage stellen du hast
in einem Interview gesagt dass solange
Journalisten vor Ort sind und auch die
Geschichte zeigt wieder das Risiko was
ihr alle auf euch nimmt das ist dann ein
kleines Stück sicherer für die Menschen
ist wie auch in anderen Kriegsgebieten
wie wäre es denn eigentlich mit
Politikern würde es irgendetwas bringen
wenn mehr Politiker europäische
Politiker deutsche Politiker auch nach
Kiew reisen würden
ja
sicherlich wobei die Frage ist sozusagen
wenn Politiker irgendwohin reisen dann
muss es mehr sein als das ich fand den
Vorschlag von Wladimir Klitschko in dem
Fall eigentlich sehr gut der gefordert
hatte dass zum Beispiel der Papst nach
Kiew kommen sollte und weitere Anführer
verschiedener Religionen dass sie hier
ein Treffen veranstalten sollten um ihre
ja Solidarität mit den Menschen in der
Ukraine auszudrücken und da würde ich
noch viel eher ja sagen
wenn wann ich jetzt könnte auch die
katholische Kirche vielleicht sogar mit
ein bisschen Eigennutz wenn man darüber
denkt wie viele negative Schlagzeilen
sie produziert haben in den vergangenen
Jahren und wie viel Schlimmes dort zu
Tage getreten ist der Papst hier in Kiew
ich glaube das wäre ein richtiges Signal
dann wollen wir mit dem von Dir
geforderten richtigen Signal der sich
aber auch Teile Weitergehen zu These von
ihnen ermortossen es geht um die
steigenden Energiepreise sehr gerne wir
haben gerade wirklich wieder
eindrucksvoll gehört und das tun wir
jeden Tag wie ernsthaft diese
Auseinandersetzung oder diese
Angriffskrieg Russlands ist und wir
bekommen auch mit was das für Folgen hat
für unsere Sanktionen die wir vollends
unterstützen und die auch auf lange
Sicht weiter durchgehalten werden müssen
natürlich bedeutet das dass wir in
Deutschland höhere Rohstoffpreise haben
weil wir und das sind außenpolitische
Einschätzungen die in der Vergangenheit
gemacht wurden eine zu große
Abhängigkeit bei Energieträgern von
Russland entwickelt haben deswegen wird
er ja auch schrittweise rausholen
dennoch kann man die Menschen mit diesen
Spritpreisen nicht alleine lassen und
deswegen bin ich sehr froh dass unser
Bundesfinanzminister dazu ein sehr
konkreten Vorschlag gemacht hat wie wir
die Menschen entlassen können entlasten
können ich kann natürlich nicht genau
sagen wie hoch da sein wird und wann das
beginnt aber es ist das
schnellstmögliche wir haben das wirklich
sehr genau geprüft und ich freue mich
sehr dass dieser Vorschlag jetzt auf dem
Tisch liegt und natürlich auch auf die
Diskussion
ja da muss ich antworten denn damit habe
ich nicht gehört wir haben ja zwei
Stränge der eine Strang ist die Energie
wir haben den teuer Schock durch den
Krieg den spüren wir jeden Tag nicht nur
das natürlich auch durch die Zulieferung
von Teilen die Lieferketten unterbrochen
sind dass vor allem auch für die
Automobilindustrie als eine ganz harte
Zeit ist die Bänder stehen still die
Leute gehen in Kurzarbeit und dann
kommen sie nach Hause und haben auch
noch die erhöhten Energiepreise da ist
das Paket des geschnürt wurde von dieser
Ampelkoalition von dieser
Bundesregierung zu klein und auf der
jetzt aktuellen Seite dieser
rabattvorschlag von Christian Lindner da
muss ich einfach sagen der ist viel zu
kurz gesprungen und auch viel zu
kompliziert also die FDP hat sich immer
aufgeschaukelt als eine
entbürokratisierungspartei ich kann mich
erinnern bei der bohrpflicht für den
Bäcker und wieder von von vielen anderen
mittelständischen Betrieben hat die FDP
eigentlich eine Kampagne gemacht jetzt
macht sie dasselbe für mich ist
entscheidend dass es beim Preisschild
darum geht wenn man an der Tankstelle
vorbei fährt dass die Anzeige den
Warenpreis wiedergibt ich bin im
Grenzraum wo viel Tanktourismus momentan
zu Österreich ist da ist entscheidend
was
dort ausgewiesen ist als Preis da fährt
nicht einer hin und schaut dann und sagt
welchen Rabatt bekomme ich dann tanke
ich das rein dann gehe ich zum Tankwart
dann sage ich BITTE BITTE ich habe meine
Karten sowieso nie dabei die die
Bankkarten ja das kommt noch erschwerend
hinzu und dann kriege ich noch ein
Rabatt und der
Tankstellenbetreiber soll dann mit dem
Finanzminister abrechnen da ist könnten
sie denn überhaupt immer selbst
natürlich
ja natürlich und deswegen weiß ich auch
im Unterschied zum Bundeskanzler was der
Liter Sprit kostet
32 also da ist sogar der Diesel jetzt
noch teurer durch die Heizöl
Abfragen viermal so hoch wie sonst sieht
man dass die Leute in Panik sind und
dementsprechend es ist ganz einfach
schlagen sie von der Ampelkoalition
etwas vor in dieser Woche und wir machen
40 Cent günstiger dann kommen wir unter
die zwei Euro und wie erreichen wir das
erstens Reduzierung der Energiesteuer
zweitens Reduzierung der Mehrwertsteuer
drittens eine erhöhte Beimischungsquote
für biographstoffe dann helfen wir nicht
nur den Privatsektor sondern vor allem
auch im Gewerbe vor allem dem
Speditionsgewerbe uns darf nicht
passieren dass die Lieferketten
unterbrochen werden uns darf nicht
passieren dass 47.000 Unternehmen in der
speditions- und Logistikbranche die
selber auf dem Hof beim Logistikzentrum
meistens betriebstankstellen haben dass
diese Speditionen ihren Betrieb
einstellen müssen weil sie die Preise
nicht mehr weitergeben können und die
legalregale leer sind da wäre dann die
Ampel dafür verantwortlich für diese
leeren Regale und das will ich nicht
deswegen ein ehrliches Angebot diese
Woche abstimmen können
sie wurden ja selbst so oft mit
Forderungen zugeballert als
Verkehrsmittel dürfen sie auch meine
sitzen und schön drauf aber ich hoffe
Sie genießen in verschiedenen Zeit bleib
halt dann glaubwürdig weil ich habe
nämlich vor der Bundestagswahl am 06.09
die spritpreisbremse gefordert wenn es
über dafür aber auch absehbar also Herr
Kollege sie sind noch sehr jung dabei im
Bundestag aber
6.9.2021 war vor der Bundestagswahl ja
aber da war ja schon da war ich in der
comments und da war ich im Gleichschritt
mit dem
FDP-Vorsitzenden Lindner der hat die
spritpreisbremse auch gefordert ich kann
es nachweisen schauen Sie bei Bild
gefahren auch im Archiv und am 13.10
habe ich noch mal nach der Wahl des
gefordert wenn es über die 2 € geht und
jetzt könnt ihr glaubwürdig sein
Christian Lindner könnte glaubwürdig
sein und bei der spritpreisbremse sowie
von der Union vorgeschlagen mit man
erwirbt aber keine Glaubwürdigkeit bei
den Menschen wenn man eu-rechtswidrige
Vorschläge macht und die dann umsetzt
und die werden dann wieder kassiert also
ich weiß die haben oft eine bereits
Auffassung als der EuGH aber sie wissen
selbst die Mehrwertsteuer in Deutschland
die kann nicht mal eben ermäßigt werden
denn die Mehrwertsteuersystemrichtlinie
regelt in Anhang 3 und Artikel 102 auf
welche Produkte der mäßigte
warum haben wir es bei Gastro Produkten
Lebensmittel geht und die sind in die
sind in Anhang drei aufgeführt also da
gehen sie die Nummern durch das ist sehr
sehr leicht das zu fordern wenn man es
aber nicht rechtskonform macht dann wird
es am Ende wieder kassiert und deswegen
sage ich ja gerade wir können auch
gleich noch mal über die Energiesteuer
sprechen wir haben uns das sehr genau
angeschaut wir haben sehr genau auch
gerechnet was hat am Ende welche
Auswirkungen und wir können nie
garantieren dass die Rohstoffpreise sich
nicht wieder so erhöhen dass das
eingeholt wird also das sind
Weltmarktpreise und deswegen muss man
erstens aufpassen dass das Geld auch an
die Menschen zurückkommt und nicht
irgendwo bei Öl Multis oder so versinkt
und andererseits muss man es
eu-rechtskonform machen ich bin auch
dafür und ein bisschen enttäuscht dass
man das auf EU-Ebene sie haben gerade
gesagt ich bin noch jung da lernt man
noch einiges dass man das auf EU eben
nicht so einfach mal machen kann und
gerade Notsituation würde ich mir da
mehr Flexibilität wünschen wir müssen
aber jetzt konkret mit dem arbeiten was
wir haben und da sagen wir 20 30 Cent je
nachdem dieser Krankheit der Vorschlag
von Christian
lustig
15 Cent machen wir 20 Cent ab 1 April
deswegen müssen wir doch eigentlich
sagen sind wir mal besser als die
Franzosen werden schon dazu sagen der
Preis für ein Liter Sprit in Frankreich
ist momentan unter zwei Euro wenn
nämlich 1,97 die haben ein ganz anderes
Steuerniveau wir sind weit über dem
Mindeststeuersatz den die EU vorgibt und
deswegen wundere ich mich gerade weil
dann hat der Christian Lindner im
Wahlkampf nach ihrer These was Europa
rechtswidriges gemacht jetzt sage ich
Ihnen wissen Sie dieser Vorschlag ist ja
schnell gekommen weil letzte Woche hat
ja Christian Lindner gesagt es wird noch
gar nichts gemacht jetzt heute machen
wir auf mit einem neuen Vorschlag einem
Mini Rabatt und sofort in der Sekunde
widerspricht SPD und Grüne das ist doch
Chaos die Menschen machen wir doch
einfach in dieser Woche einen klares
Signal der Entlastung für die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger mit den Stimmen
der Union wenn es in die richtige
Richtung geht nämlich die drei Punkte
die ich angesprochen hat gesagt dass wir
gar nichts machen wollen
am Bahnhof ich finde es ja total schön
dass ich Politiker mal über Verfahren
streiten weil normalerweise sind ja
immer die großen Visionen ich sehe den
Unterschied jetzt noch nicht noch nicht
so ganz ist das gerade jetzt nur ein
unterbietungswettkampf wäre sozusagen am
meisten
Sense auf den Tisch legen kann oder wo
liegt eigentlich der Unterschied also
wenn ich meiner Mutter jetzt erklären
muss das eine oder das andere dass das
wäre das richtige wo ist der Unterschied
wir haben ja wirklich und das ist
wirklich wichtig dass man es konkret
vielleicht mal kurz aufdröselt weil das
ein wirkliches Problem ist was ich auch
generell in Deutschland sehe was man
auch mal langfristig angehen könnte aber
jetzt müssen wir kurzfristig ran der
Benzin Dieselpreis der bildet sich in
Deutschland zu einem großen Teil nicht
aus dem Rohstoffpreis sondern aus
Energiesteuer die beträgt beim Benzin 65
Cent beim Diesel 47 aus der
Mehrwertsteuer jetzt noch CO2-Preis also
da gibt es sehr konkrete Ansätze die man
fahren kann natürlich wollen wir nicht
Weltmarktpreise subventionieren aber
wenn wir es dann rechtssicher für die
Menschen auch machen wollen dann müssen
wir sehr konkret und auch sehr
rechtskonform umsetzen denn ansonsten
verlieren die Menschen noch mehr
Vertrauen und diese Aussetzung der
Energiesteuer ich habe gerade Sätze
genannt wir sind uns einig wir wollen
nicht die Staatseinnahmen völlig
leerlaufen lassen mal sagen wir mal wir
setzen das aus dann sinkt der
Benzinpreis um akut 65 Cent finde ich
ganz interessante Idee kann ich auch
diskutieren aber was ist wenn wir die
wieder einsetzen dann ist der Start
verantwortlich für 65 Cent plus damit
sind wir schon ich habe keine Angst also
Sie haben es ja 16 Jahre alt
ihre Mutter sehr sehr einfach erklären
beim Herr Lindner steht weiterhin der
Spritpreis auf auf der Anzeige nämlich
zwei Euro 30 du gehst zum Tanken Tanks
gehst rein und holst den mit diesen
Preis einen Rabatt vom Tankwart der
wiederum abrechnet dann später diesen
Rabatt mit dem Finanzen übrigens nicht
über eine Schublade voller Bons also
wunderbar
das ist ihre Variante unsere Variante
ist lasst den Preis oben stehen an der
Straße mit dem reduzierten
steuerminderungsbetrag über
Energiesteuer und über Mehrwertsteuer
mit einer erhöhten Beimischungsquote und
die steuerfrei dann hätten wir auch noch
was fürs Klima getan und dann zahlst du
einfach diese
1.97 an der Zapfsäule und du brauchst
nur tanken Zahlen wieder gehen und
nichts verrechnen
ich finde es aber auch sehr spannend
würde ich gerne einmal zu paar
ronsheimer noch mal aus Kiew eine etwas
übergeordnetere Frage stellen Paul die
sich ja auch viele deutsche Fragen mit
Blick auf die steigenden tankpreise
Energiepreise du hast eben schon das Öl
embargo angesprochen müssen wir
Deutschen für die teilzahlen du bist vor
Ort
in gewisser Weise
tragen wir natürlich Konsequenzen
unseres moralischen Handelns das wäre
eine Lüge zu sagen das ist nicht der
Fall aber man muss sich diese Frage eben
glaube ich viel größer stellen als
einfach zu sagen machen wir das jetzt
weil in der Ukraine krieghersteller am
Ende geht es um unsere Werte auch um
unsere Freiheit und und vor allem um die
Frage was könnte Wladimir Putin als
nächstes tun und was tut er wenn er hier
in der Ukraine Erfolg hat greift er dann
ein natoland an würde mir selensky hat
in einem der Interviews die ich mit ihm
geführt hat gesagt wer weiß vielleicht
steht da irgendwann in Ostberlin das mag
jetzt der ein oder andere Zuschauer oder
die ein oder andere Zuschauerin für
völlig verrückt halten aber viele hier
oder viele in Deutschland haben auch
mich und andere für verrückt erklärt als
ich gesagt habe es ist nicht
ausgeschlossen dass bald Krieg um Kiew
geführt wird und darüber reden wir schon
viele Jahre von daher ist bei Wladimir
Putin ganz generell gar nichts mehr
ausgeschlossen wenn wir uns die
Benzinpreis Diskussion anhören dann
finde ich sehr wichtig dass die geführt
wird denn es ist natürlich einfach für
jemanden wie mich der ein sehr gutes
Gehalt hat zu sagen frieren wir die für
die Freiheit und und Dinge wie das ja da
das ist etwas wo man eben mit den
Menschen sprechen muss die weniger Geld
im Portemonnaie haben und vor allem muss
die Politik Ihnen helfen das ist ein
sozialen Ausgleich gibt denn ich glaube
das Schlimmste und ich bewerte es ja
ganz bewusst auch von hier aus der
ukrainischen Perspektive wäre wenn
dadurch eine ja soziale Explosion
entsteht in Deutschland so will ich es
einmal nennen Leute die wütend sind weil
sie die Zeche zahlen müssen und dann
sich die Wut auf die Ukraine und entlädt
und wer etwas was wir unbedingt
verändern müssen und deswegen finde ich
diese Diskussion wahnsinnig wichtig und
vor allem egal da bin ich jetzt nicht im
technischen so drin aber egal in welcher
Form und ich glaube ganz besonders
wichtig ist dass es schnell passiert
genau das eine Lehre wurde ja auch jetzt
glücklicherweise aus dem furchtbaren
Krieg Putins gezogen und das ist dass
wir die Bundeswehr sträflich
vernachlässigt haben in Deutschland und
da zahlt uns heute Herr Dr Möllinger
sein Thema seine Thesen seien Aufreger
mitgebracht ja es geht um noch mehr Geld
100 Milliarden Euro wollen wir ausgeben
unter anderem hat der Bundeskanzler Herr
Lindner zugerufen das soll jetzt
ausgegeben werden 100 Milliarden wofür
das ist die Frage auf der einen Seite
hat große Begeisterungsstürme gegeben
bei der Industrie und bei der ein oder
anderen Partei in Deutschland das hier
ist auf einmal ganz schnell ganz viel
Geld freigegeben wird in Wirklichkeit
ist es so das ist eine kleine
Schatztruhe aus der wir eben nicht jeden
Tag unser Essen bezahlen können das was
die Streitkräfte jeden Tag brauchen der
Munition sondern es ist genau für die
Anschaffung gedacht die wir letzten 30
Jahren nicht tätigen konnten weil wir
kein Geld auf der hohen Kante hatten das
heißt von diesen 100 Milliarden müssen
wir die ganz großen Dinge kaufen das
heißt neue Panzer neue Flugzeuge alles
das was wir eigentlich seit 20 Jahren
versprochen haben zu haben auf dass sich
unsere europäischen Partner verlassen
haben und wir hatten es nicht wenn
dieses Geld jetzt innerhalb der
kürzester Zeit ausgegeben wird durch die
Bundesregierung weil sie eigentlich ganz
gerne möchte dass sie keine neuen
Schulden extra noch aufnehmen muss dann
ist das genau das Falsche wir brauchen
dieses Geld dazu um die großen Projekte
die über 10 15 Jahre laufen am Ende
bezahlen zu können es ist so als ob sie
ein Auto heute bestellen und in zehn
Jahren bezahlen müssen da müssen sie das
Geld dazu haben das hat mir bislang
nicht und diese 100 Milliarden bieten
uns einmalig die Gelegenheit das
auszugeben ich hoffe dass wir nicht den
Fehler machen und kurzfristig darauf
setzen dass die Steuern nicht nach oben
gehen oder das die Schuldenbremse die
Erwägung ist also Finanzpolitik sondern
Sicherheit Artikeln in der Tat wir haben
nur weniger Kilometer von hier entfernt
wenige tausend Kilometer von hier
entfernt einen Grieß man fragt sich wie
nah muss die muss die Problematik müssen
die Bedrohung noch an Europa rankommen
bevor wir tatsächlich eher militärisch
und sicherheitspolitisch denken und
nicht finanzpolitisch und vor allem wenn
man das noch betrachtet für die heutige
Entscheidung der F35 Bestellung dann
haben wir damit natürlich auch die von
den Grünen immer bestrittene nukleare
Teilhabe fixiert wenn man an dieser
Stelle dieses Flugzeug nimmt dann sind
wir in der Bestellung eines us-produkts
darin dass diese diese Maschine
natürlich auch die solche Waffen tragen
kann genau das stimmt man muss
allerdings fairerweise sagen die Grünen
haben wir den Koalitionsvertrag mit
unterschrieben und da ist die nukleare
Teilhabe reingehämmert worden das heißt
da bestand jetzt kein Zweifel mehr daran
dass dieses Flugzeug bestellt oder das
ein Flugzeug bestellt wird wir haben
jetzt noch eine politische Entscheidung
obendrauf wo sogar der Typ genannt
worden ist erstaunlich dass das jetzt
auf einmal so schnell gegangen ist gut
als Nachricht an unsere Partner das kann
man schon sagen das ist auch eine
Ausnahme weil das geht jetzt ganz
schnell also relativ schnell im Kauf wir
haben aber andere Produkte wo wir ganz
klar sagen da wollen wir als auch unsere
deutsche Industrie letztendlich nicht
nur daran verdienen sondern sie auch
weiterentwickeln das geht nicht nur für
Bayern sondern das gilt auch für andere
Länder in denen das von Interesse ist
von daher geht es darum eben das Geld
strategisch auszugeben und nicht zu
sagen raus mit der Kohle
damit die deutsche Industrie viel Geld
damit verdient sondern wir als
Steuerzahler und wir als Land haben
Interesse daran dass wir in den nächsten
20 Jahren nicht noch mal auf
amerikanische Produkte unbedingt
zurückgreifen müssen sondern das wird
tatsächlich das was wir verschlafen
haben nachholen und in 20 Jahren wieder
auf europäische Produkte zurückgreifen
kann und wenn man sie sind da der Profi
aber wenn man diese diesen Krieg
anschaut dann sind er auch die
bewaffneten Drohnen die in der von
ukrainische Armee angewendet sind
durchaus ja wirksam gegen die russische
Armee die SPD hat sich in der letzten
Bundesregierung immer
dagegen gewährt die haben sie
Technologie
einzusetzen die bewaffnete Drohne und
ich hoffe dass diese Liste die dann
erstellt wird über die 100 Milliarden
Invest auch einen großen Anteil an
europäischer Technologie drin hat
besser schlau als schnell ausgeben das
gefällt mir als Steuerzahlerin natürlich
auch sehr gut ich glaube das gefällt
jedem gut aber meine Frage ist ganz klar
wie viel Zeit bleibt uns denn also wir
haben ja jetzt so viel Jahrzehnte ist
total versaut also haben wir jetzt
überhaupt noch diese Planungszeit oder
müssen wir jetzt eigentlich nicht ganz
schnell reagieren und vielleicht dann
sogar hinnehmen das ein bisschen was aus
dem Ruder läuft ja also erstmal die
Planung sind da das ist die gute
Nachricht ja also es gibt tatsächlich
muss man sagen eine Schublade die man
aufmachen kann wo drin steht das
brauchen wir alles denn wir haben das ja
vor Jahren zugesagt dass wir es liefern
und diese Sachen müssen wir liefern
natürlich kannst du noch mal hier unter
Abweichung geben davon aber das ist
nicht so wichtig wir wissen eigentlich
was wir brauchen wir wissen aber auch
dass es das herzustellen ganz lange
dauert teilweise weil wir nämlich im
Grunde genommen sozusagen erstmal
Skizzen zeichnen müssen der Sachen die
wir eigentlich haben wollen zumindest
die die wir in Deutschland produzieren
wollen das finde ich auch richtig das
heißt also jetzt ganz schnell heißt aber
auch dass ich in 10 15 Jahren dann
nichts modernes mehr habe sondern ich
kaufe das was jetzt schon da ist das
heißt macht es eigentlich der Mix aus
ich brauche ein paar Sachen ganz schnell
die brauche ich auch nicht in
Deutschland kaufen die kann ich in den
USA kaufen aber es gibt andere Sachen
die stellen wir in Deutschland
eigentlich gut her deswegen würde ich
sagen sollten wir sie in Deutschland
kaufen und dann müssen wir uns aber 10
15 Jahre gedulden das was wir jetzt
ausgeben hilft uns mit Blick auf die
jetzigen Risiken die wir haben in
Deutschland und in Europa mit Blick auf
Putin nichts mehr hier geht es darum
dass das was wir 30 Jahre lang wirklich
nicht gut gemacht haben sie haben gesagt
so kann man es auch sagen stimmt dass
wir das Nachholen das braucht da aber
seine Zeit denn das was wir auch alle
Fälle nicht wollen oder ich möchte es
nicht und ich glaube die
Regierungsparteien möchten es auch nicht
ist am Ende Legislatur da stehen ein
paar halbfertige Produkte zu haben und
ein paar gute Skandale zu haben in dem
viel zu viel Geld für schlechte Produkte
ausgegeben worden ist wenn ich dazu nur
eine Randnotiz machen darf weil sie da
der Experte sind und ich mich
hauptsächlich mit Finanz und
digitalpolitik beschäftige aber
erstens dieses Sondervermögen ist ja da
um das aufzuholen was sie uns gesagt 30
Jahre
versäumt wurde damit soll schnell was
passieren immer auch schlau also ähnlich
wie bei der wie bei den Spritpreisen
schlau und schnell schließen sich
hoffentlich nicht aus aber wir haben ja
auch gesagt wir halten das 2% Ziel der
NATO ein das ist auch ein aufwuchs an
Militärausgaben den wir dann ja über die
nächsten Jahre konsequent leisten werden
und und da kennen sich noch mal besser
aus Beschaffungswesen Struktur und so
weiter sind ein Riesenthema auch das
wollen wir ja angehen da bin ich auf die
ersten Vorschläge gespannt ja gehört
auch mit dazu absolut ich glaube der
größte Fehler den wir jetzt machen
können ist und das war bis die letzten
Tage noch glaube ich das große Interesse
auch ihrer Partei dass wir dieses Geld
eben so schnell ausgeben damit es im
Grunde noch auf die Schulden mit
angerechnet werden kann und wir im
Grunde genommen nicht in die Situation
kommen noch zusätzliches Geld aufzugeben
das wäre aus meiner Sicht das falsche
wir sollten dieses Geld über 10 bis 15
Jahre Strecken und wirklich nur ich sag
mal den Rolls-Royce daraus bezahlen und
nicht den Sprit für den Rolls-Royce
bitte
wir sind ja glaube ich sie sind noch ein
bisschen jünger aber ich glaube aus
einer Generation könnte man noch sagen
auf jeden Fall
habe die Jugend also auch viele auch aus
unserer Generation oder auch noch jünger
die sagen ja immer gerne klimaklima
Klima und Bundeswehr war ja immer völlig
egal und eigentlich waren eh alles
Pazifisten Heckler und Koch durfte der
damals nichtmals an die Flut Opfer im
Aartal spenden weil das war ja verpönt
in Deutschland also er Pazifismus hat ja
eigentlich regiert wie schaffen wir es
denn jetzt vielleicht auch vor allem
auch bei den Jungen Wählerinnen und
Wählern und generell in der Gesellschaft
auch wieder ja dass wir das Brot
brauchen also die Sinnhaftigkeit
darzustellen ich war damals schon
schockiert bei Heckler und Koch aber ich
muss auch jetzt sagen das muss ich auch
was ändern in der Wahrnehmung völlig
richtig ist muss ich was ändern an der
Mentalität also grenzenloser Pazifismus
ist eben nicht realistisch er kann
Menschenleben kosten wie wir da sehr
ernsthaft sehen und deswegen müssen wir
da immer das richtige Maß finden ich
würde nicht sagen dass dieses Klischee
über die die Jugend so stimmt also wir
wollen auch klimakima aber trotzdem hat
haben die Erstwähler relativer Mehrheit
uns gewählt und wir machen ja auch
andere Vorschläge in anderen Bereichen
deswegen glaube ich dass die Jugend da
sehr differenziert ist und ich ich habe
vor allem aus meinem Umfeld aus Menschen
die auch eher mir in den sozialen Medien
folgen was ja die sich für meine Politik
interessieren sehr viel positives
Feedback zu dieser
verteidigungsausrüstung gehört und ich
glaube das hat mich auch ziemlich
zuversichtlich gestimmt dass wir da
jetzt auf den richtigen Weg gehen wenn
wir es vernünftig machen also wenn wir
jetzt die politische Lage uns anschauen
dann muss diese Ampel 1 den verhandelten
Koalitionsvertrag durch die dramatische
Lage des nichtkalkulierbaren
Krieges Russlands gegen Ukraine
eigentlich schon mal beiseite legen wir
diskutieren über Aufrüstung wird
diskutieren über die Verlängerung des
kohleausstiegs in weitere Jahrzehnte und
wir diskutieren über den Weiterbetrieb
von
Atommeilern weil nur so können wir diese
dramatische Situation
überwinden und dann schaue ich in gerade
zwei Fraktionen in dieser Koalition
nämlich in die grüne Fraktion und in die
SPD-Fraktion und stelle fest da werde
ich mir das anschauen wie die Diskussion
läuft es ist ungefähr so wie heute das
jetzt gerade die Meldungen kommen dass
die Grünen dem lindnerschen
fdp-tankrabatt gleich meine Absage
erzeugen aber in der in der
Gesamtschau muss man das schon anschauen
also wir haben nicht nur global
geopolitisch eine Zeitenwende eine
Zeitenwende wie es der Bundeskanzler
gesagt hat sondern eine unser Simons
einig zeitenwände in vielen vielen
Themen die wir in den letzten
Jahrzehnten vielleicht auch einer ja
sehr globalen pazifistischen Sicht
dargelegt haben und jetzt sind wir eines
besseren belehrt also ich wünsche Liebe
Koalition bei diesem Vorhaben sehr viel
Freude in der Diskussion aber ich sage
wir brauchen die Aufrüstung wir brauchen
den Weiterbetrieb der Atom Meiler und
wir brauchen auch eine einen längeren
Zeitplan für den Kohleausstieg und da
werden noch viele Fragen auf Sie
zukommen wir können feststellen jetzt
schon in der ersten Hälfte dass Herr
scheuer in der Rolle der Opposition sich
sehr
wohl fallen wir aber erstmal noch mal
live aus Kiel auf direkt nach der
Werbung wie es Paul dort ergeht wie
seine Eindrücke waren heute
wir sind zurück und gerade viel hier in
unserer Diskussion in der Pause
natürlich diskutieren wir auch dort
weiter viel Grad eine Frage die ich
direkt an pauronsheimer stellen möchte
er ist der stellvertreten Stoffwechsel
vom Bild und jeden Abend uns live aus
Kiew zurückgeschaltet Paul Grad fiel die
Frage hier braucht Wladimir Putin Kiew
das ist eine sehr gute Frage die wenn
man sie beantworten könnte vielleicht
schon einiges klarer machen würde also
fangen wir zu Beginn des Krieges an da
muss man sagen da die mir putin hatte
definitiv vor Kiew zu erobern er wollte
einen anderen Präsidenten einsetzen das
zeigen sie wohl Geheimdienstberichte als
auch alle weiteren Indikationen jetzt
sind bereits fast 19 Tage vergangen in
diesem Krieg und Kiew ist nicht so
leicht zu bekommen das zeigt sich sowohl
militärisch als auch in dem
wirtschaftlichen Druck den es
mittlerweile auf Russland gibt ich wage
die These dass wenn Russland mit allem
was es hat
mit weiteren Kämpfern aus Syrien mit
Kämpfern möglicherweise aus Weißrussland
hier weiter vormarschiert dass man
irgendwann Kiew kaputt Bomben könnte
aber Putin könnte Kiew niemals haben
denn man sieht hier ein dermaßen großen
Willen Widerstand zu leisten
das ist am Ende ein Häuserkampf werden
würde das ist partisangruppen geben
würde die immer wieder angreifen das ist
ja das wahre Problem eigentlich in
dieser Frage also aus Putins Sicht er
hatte möglicherweise naiv möglicherweise
falsch beraten geglaubt dass zumindest
in vielen Teilen der Ukraine er
irgendwie mit offenen Armen empfangen
würde also ich glaube er hat seinen
eigenen Lügen am Ende geglaubt
insbesondere was den Osten angeht aber
auch selbst dort sehen wir massiven
Widerstand also er hatte sich sicherlich
vorgestellt dass Städte wie Haki wie
Mario Pool Odessa viel viel schneller
fallen sind natürlich je weiter westlich
es geht in der Ukraine desto
komplizierter ist es für ihn hier ist
ein Symbol geworden
Kiew ist aus meiner Sicht für Putin
nicht zu bekommen zumindest nicht
dauerhaft zu besetzen denn wenn man das
ganze Land besetzen will braucht er
dauerhaft hunderttausende Soldaten wie
soll das gehen also das würde selbst
dann auch die russische Wirtschaft und
das russische Militär weiter dahin
raffen deswegen geht es für ihn momentan
darum vor allem eine gute
Ausgangsposition für weitere
Verhandlungen zu bekommen oder erstmal
starten eine Verhandlung zu bekommen und
das ist das was auf beiden Seiten gerade
passiert und das ist auch ein bisschen
ich nenne es schlimm ist doch
moralisches Dilemma für den ukrainischen
Präsidenten der immer jeden Tag
entscheiden muss
kann ich das meinem Volk noch antun auf
der einen Seite und auch auf der anderen
Seite was ist wenn ich aufgebe oder auf
bestimmte Bedingungen eingehe macht mein
Volk das mit das sind ganz ganz schwere
Tage und Wochen die vor würde ein
bisschen ins gestehen
wichtige Informationen aus Kiew live von
paronsheimer der heute Abend hier auch
die ganze Zeit wie in Amberg 8:15 Uhr
vor Ort ist und jetzt machen wir weiter
mit der These von andreas Scheuer
Fasching es tut mir leid ich muss
das Thema ändern
denn sie haben mich aufgerufen über
Lindners Tankrabatt
auf jeden Fall denke ich ist ja dazu
alles gesagt nur ein Einsatz wir wollen
als Union über die Steuer über 40 Cent
beim Sprit nachlassen und da ist das
Angebot an die Ampelkoalition gesetzt
keinen kleinen mini-rabatt aller immer
Tee sondern sondern wirkliche Entlastung
aber das eine kommt mit dem anderen
zusammen nämlich dass wir in Deutschland
diesen Krieg spüren spüren werden auch
in den kommenden Monaten und da müssen
wir alles jetzt daran liegen in einer
Welt die komplizierte geworden ist wenn
ich beispielsweise die Taiwan
Problematik mit China sehe die
Lieferketten die globalen die
Exportwirtschaft in Deutschland und die
größte Logistikbranche der Welt nämlich
in Deutschland Logistik Weltmeister lebt
davon dass wir
betroffen sind dass wir auch
funktionierende Lieferketten haben und
deswegen braucht es ein starkes
Deutschland des bündnistreu ist das in
der Europäischen Union eine starke
Stimme hat aber das was wir jetzt
brauchen in Deutschland um den sozialen
Frieden zu gewährleisten ist runter bei
den Energiepreisen runter bei den
Spritpreisen damit wir auch die
Solidarität dafür haben und die Stärke
dafür haben aus unserer wirtschaftlichen
Kraft heraus die kommenden Monate wo es
auch
Migrationsströme geben wird zu meistern
und da müssen wir jetzt darauf achten
dass wir diese Balance halten diese
Balance zum einen in der globalen
Verantwortung in unserem Wissen über
eine starke Außenpolitik zu kommen und
auch über eine Bündnispolitik die schlau
ist um dann eines zu erreichen nämlich
das Putin endlich aufhört zu Bomben und
da ist meine These wir brauchen auch die
die auf russischer Seite das Geld haben
dazu den Druck auf
zu erhöhen denn momentan ist nur auf
russischer Seite Putin und ich würde mir
wünschen dass wir bald über eine nachput
in Zeit reden können und es geht nur mit
einem Druck aus Russland heraus das ist
jetzt noch weit weg wir brauchen erst
den ersten Schritt nämlich den Frieden
in der Ukraine aber das muss unser aller
Aufgabe sein wir werden sehen dass wir
mit diesem
Putin Krieg an dieser Stelle Schluss
machen müssen und alles darin tun müssen
dass wieder die Partnerschaft mit auch
russischen Menschen ob das über die
Wissenschaft ist ob das über die
Wirtschaft ist sich in langfristig
entwickelt weil mit Putin wird vieles
zerstört werden was mir unglaublich
Angst macht
sozialer Sprengstoff Herr Mordhorst wie
sehen Sie das denn naja also natürlich
wird das sozialen Sprengstoff mit sich
bringen wir sind zu einer großen
Abhängigkeit von russischer Energie
gekommen die wir jetzt verlassen müssen
und ich möchte da wirklich auch mal
respekt für meinen sowohl gleiches
Bundesland als auch andere Parteien
nämlich Robert Habeck Aussprechen der
das sehr sehr klar gesagt hat wir müssen
energiepolitisch unabhängig werden das
wird teuer werden das wird auch den
Menschen etwas abverlangen wir versuchen
da abzufedern zu dämpfen aber ich will
die Leute auch nicht anlügen wir müssen
uns jetzt verändern wir müssen
Entscheidungen was die Energie was die
Wirtschaft was die Sicherheit angeht
strategischer begreifen längerfristiger
begreifen und deswegen glaube ich
stimmen wir im Grundsatz überein obwohl
ich jetzt nicht so ganz den Punkt genau
verstanden habe aber ich glaube wir sind
uns einig wir müssen energiepolitisch
unabhängig werden und mehr
Entscheidungen strategischer und
langfristiger betrachten richtig dann
fordere ich aber ein dass er habe ich
nicht nur nach innen agiert sondern
jetzt so wie es die Amerikaner machen
nach neue Partnerschaften gründet in der
Versorgung mit beispielsweise teilweise
Erdöl und Kohle den da müssen jetzt neue
Partnerschaften gegründet werden und das
zweite sage ich ihnen voraus dass wir
einen Reset brauchen einen kompletten
Reset der europäischen
Landwirtschaftspolitik weil wir werden
nämlich über versorgungssicherheiten
reden bei den Lebensmitteln wenn wir uns
darauf verlassen haben in der Ukraine
Weizen anzubauen und auf europäischer
Ebene lieber flächenlegungen machen oder
renaturierungsprogramme oder den Zubau
auf fruchtbaren Boden durch regenerative
Energien verbauen dann werden wir hier
viele viele Fragen noch mal neu
diskutieren müssen in der Europäischen
Union die Landwirtschaftspolitik ist
sehr europäisch geprägt weil ich glaube
dass das notwendig ist um genau das zu
erreichen was die richtige Weise sagen
eine neue souveränitätsdebatte in
Deutschland und Europa zu machen
souverän von allen anderen Dingen wir
haben über bei der corona-pandemie über
einen
textlappen geredet nehmen namens Maske
dass man das aus China brauchen und
haben uns beklagt dass wir keine eigene
Produktion haben das ist das ist locker
zu machen über was wir jetzt in diesem
Russland Krieg und den Folgen reden ist
über Lebensmittel über viele viele
langfristige Dinge
ja natürlich sage ich Ihnen ganz bewusst
ich habe in den letzten Jahren und
Jahrzehnten erlebt dass wir uns immer
stärker auf andere verlassen und dass
wir vielleicht auch einen
Transformationsprozess anstoßen den ich
sogar ganz unterstützen möchte was die
Ökologie betrifft und die Ökonomie
betrifft dass wir eine andere Produktion
haben andere Antriebstechnologien
Innovation an erster Stelle setzen
völlig okay aber trotzdem braucht es
einen Reset in einer
souveränitätsdebatte gerade wenn ich an
die Landwirtschaftspolitik denke da
haben die Bäuerinnen und Bauern viel
viel mitgemacht mit der Europäischen
Union und da möchte ich eine andere
Strategie aus den Lehrern dieser
Situation wissen sie Einsatz noch ich
habe ich habe einen Senior Landwirt der
sich eine Lebenstraum erfüllt hat in der
Ukraine als Bayer als Deutscher dort
junge Menschen auszubilden in einer
riesen Landwirtschaft die junge
Generation hat den Betrieb in meinem
Wahlkreis Passau übernommen und diese
Lebensraum der ist jetzt zerstört weil
er sagt ich habe immer darauf gebaut
dass wir in einer friedlichen Welt leben
und dass wir gemeinsam gesunde
Lebensmittel produzieren und das müssen
wir neu diskutieren und ehrlich
diskutieren
Herr Dr Meiling hier ist schon sehr
Germany ich muss sagen ich muss sagen
ich bin leidenschaftlich Europäerin ich
sage auch im Ausland ich komme aus
Europa und ich komme aus Deutschland ich
glaube an den vereinigtes Europa muss
man nicht auch sagen dass eigentlich die
Europäische Union und so lange auf den
Frieden gebracht hat also ich meine die
Zusammenhalt der Länder ist doch der
Grund warum wir so lange keinen Krieg
hatten oder das ist sicherlich so dass
kann man ganz klar unterstreichen also
Europa ist ein Friedensprojekt nach
innen hin gewesen jetzt ist die Frage
kann ich das auch nach außen sein wir
sehen ja das viel der Sachen die gerade
passieren die jetzt nicht so mondän
Aussehen trotzdem durch die Europäische
Union geleistet werden also
Energiesicherheit organisieren wir nicht
in der NATO und die sind auch nicht
national sondern die organisieren wir
europäisch da hat Deutschland
Nachholbedarf ja das muss auch ganz klar
sagen aber wenn wir jetzt über neue
Partnerschaften reden dann ist die Frage
sind es wirklich neue qualitativ oder
fallen wenn die alte Falle neu
Abhängigkeiten rein das heißt wir müssen
uns unsere neuen Partner schon genau
angucken also wer sind denn wenn sie
kohlenlieferanten haben wollen wer ist
denn denn dieses Land uns in Zukunft die
Kohle liefert neben den Umweltfragen
dass man beseitigt gestellt was mich
interessieren würde bei den Vorschlägen
die sie machen und ich gehe im Prinzip
mit bei ihnen beiden ich gehe mal davon
aus das muss ja nachher dann doch
irgendwie bezahlt werden wer zahlt das
nachher ist es die Generation meiner
Mutter es ist meine Generation und es
ist die Generation meiner Kinder also
wie machen wir das eigentlich wann kommt
die Zeche dafür nicht dass sich das
ablehnen würde sondern die Frage ist für
mich bloß wen muss ich darauf eigentlich
vorbereiten dass er wie lange auf
bestimmten Teil von Wohlstand verzichten
muss
hier würde ich gerne auch einmal Paul in
die Debatte reinholen der hoffentlich
ich habe ja jedes mal Angst dass die
Leitung aus irgendeinem Grund nicht mehr
funktioniert nach Kiew dass meine größte
Sorge immer hier während der Sendungen
paar wenn du unsere reden hier hörst es
gibt ja auch noch eine Sache die auch
aktuell debattiert wird und zwar ob die
Ukraine vielleicht zur Europäischen
Union gehören kann oder sollte oder ob
man da einen Plan aufstellen würde die
Debatte würde ich auch gerne noch
aufmachen
ja also zur Europäischen Union und zur
möglichen Mitgliedschaft habe ich eine
klare Haltung das müsste so schnell wie
möglich passieren ich glaube zumindest
diesen Beitrittsprozess zu beschleunigen
das sind wieder Ukraine schuldig wenn
wir schon sonst wenig tun aus meiner
Sicht was den Widerstand gegen Putin
angeht da ist gerade in diesem Minuten
etwas interessantes passiert worauf ich
gerne eingehen möchte im russischen
Staatsfernsehen gab es den Protest einer
Moderatorin war es glaube ich ja dann
Journalistin die das Studio dort mehr
oder weniger gestürmt hat und gegen den
Krieg protestiert hat gegen den Krieg
demonstriert hat also es gibt diese
mutigen Menschen in Russland und wir
werden jetzt wahrscheinlich viele viele
Jahre im Gefängnis drohen aber wir sehen
zumindest zarte Pflänzchen dieses
Protest gegen Wladimir Putin und es
bleibt zu hoffen dass es weitere gibt
wir sehen das glaube ich wirklich und
bei allem was gerade Schreckliches
passiert und was einfach an jedem Tag
glaube ich auch schwer mitnimmt ist
glaube ich trotzdem wichtig eine Lehre
daraus zu ziehen die nicht ist die
Demokratie ist schwach oder unsere
westliche Vorstellung von Freiheit die
funktioniert nicht wir müssen Maßgaben
ändern wir müssen selbst selbstständiger
werden strategischer denken aber Putin
macht das doch aus Angst weil er Angst
vor seiner eigenen Bevölkerung hat weil
die Ukraine sich auf den Weg nach Westen
gemacht hat weil sie Freiheit wollte
weil sie die NATO in der Verfassung
stehen hat als verfassungsziel und es
ist jedes jeden Tag wieder schrecklich
was Sie für einen Preis dafür zahlen
müssen muss aber trotzdem sollten wir
nicht an der Idee der Demokratie in
irgendeiner Weise eine oder der Idee der
Demokratie eine Schwäche attestieren
sondern gerade zeigen das ist Stärke
dass ich auch von innen heraus etwas
ändern kann und das trotz eines solchen
massiven propaganda-apparats wie in
Russland ist trotzdem noch Menschen sich
frei informieren sich sogar trotz
größter Drohungen und Konsequenzen
dagegen wenden das macht eins macht
einem zumindest ein bisschen
wir sind noch Herr Mölling die
Antwort schuldig nämlich wer soll das
bezahlen ich glaube
fakt ist
sind wir uns einig dass wir als Deutsche
nur aus der deutschen Sicht heraus immer
schon Rohstoffe importieren mussten weil
wir selber zu wenig haben und deswegen
glaube ich dass seine große Aufgabe
beispielsweise auf die wirtschaftliche
Zusammenarbeit und Entwicklungspolitik
zukommt denn als wahre
Wirtschaftspolitik das zu verstehen und
neue Partnerschaften zu gründen
beispielsweise mit den wasserstoffen
Vorkommen in Mali die sind nicht grün
also wenn man gleich springen will in
den grünen Wasserstoff dann verkennt man
dass man zu neuen Technologien und
regenerativen Energien Brücken braucht
und das war unser Fehler der letzten
Jahre zu sagen ich gehe von dem einen
extrem in das andere ich glaube wir
müssen Brücken bauen in der dazwischen
in der Zwischenzeit um neue
Partnerschaften einzugehen also nicht
ganz alten wieder aufzurufen sondern es
haben sich in der Zwischenzeit neue
Möglichkeiten geschaffen ich habe heute
Gespräch mit einem Botschafter gehabt
von einem Land wo man nicht direkt dran
denkt dass man vielleicht dort auch
seltene Erden oder auch Rohstoffe
beziehen kann neue Partnerschaften
Gründen da hat es schon mal eine in
welchem Land war denn der Botschafter
der Botschafter war aus der Mongolei und
die Mongolei ist groß mit wenig Menschen
vielen Tieren aber auch vor allem vielen
Rohstoffen und es gab schon mal eine
Partnerschaft eine bessere Partnerschaft
zwischen Deutschland und der Mongolei um
genau neue Technologien zu entwickeln
und dass wir dann der Weg dorthin eine
so eine Pipeline Nord Stream hat auch
Geld gekostet ja also die hat auch
Milliarden verschlungen warum gehen wir
nicht an anderen Wege und suchen uns
Partner mit neuen importmöglichkeiten
über Rohstoffe und das zweite von ihnen
kann ich auch nur unterstreichen ich
glaube
ja sind ja nicht nur zum Streiten da
sondern wir haben ja viele
Gemeinsamkeiten wenn es um Krisen geht
das machen wir Deutschland immer stark
gemacht das eine ist natürlich die die
Fundamente der Demokratie auf der
anderen Seite muss ich in Russland
feststellen dass es noch zu wenige gibt
die so mutig sind weil sie Angst haben
dort sind alle sozialen Netzwerke
abgeschaltet ich glaube da kann man
wenig Verständnis
aber die letzte Minute gehört immer
paronsheimer in Kiew ja natürlich
jetzt zwei weil der Paulus mit ihrer
These deswegen
kommt jetzt poweranz einmal wie jeden
Abend das hat Tradition hier bei unserer
Film nach acht du hast 30 Sekunden Paul
und dann sind wir auch direkt raus
ich denke in diesen Sekunden an meinen
Kollegen an meinen reporterkollegen von
Fox News der heute offenbar nein der
heute ganz sicher verletzt worden ist
hier in der Nähe von Kiew ich denke an
alle Reporter weltweit die unterwegs
sind für ihren Job und natürlich denke
ich an die Menschen in den Ukraine und
bete dafür dass endlich Frieden kommt
und dass die Gespräche die angefangen
haben die anfangen sollen auch wirklich
Erfolg haben ich finde ein besseres
Schlusswort könnte es nicht geben und
damit schönen Abend noch an Sie liebe
Zuschauer
[Musik]